any video game fans here this is pretty  exciting the new Xbox 1x console comes  out tomorrow it's the most powerful I  know most powerful console in the world  and to help us all feel the true power  of the new console please welcome my  friend  Ronda Rousey  [Applause]  look fantastic  it is so it is so great to see you  Rhonda could you please explain to us  who's this guy right here this is Dustin  and he's going to help us demonstrate  exactly what it feels like to experience  true 4k gaming on the Xbox one X console  are you ready Dustin mm-hmm okay you  guys all ready to see this show I'm  Rhonda here we go  [Applause]  you see every everyone loved that you  see any reaction that is what it feels  like to play the new Xbox 1x console now  let's show them what it's like to play  with friends man  [Music]  you  you